about the people who have like
completely damaged their cartilage and
they decided to change their lifestyle
change their diet get alternative
therapy and their cartilage well it's
okay that's like regenerated I'll give
you an example so that's like a car
right that maybe you repainted it
yeah
we generate so it's not
that's why this
stuff like not really but you can't you
can't you can't go through three toxic
relationships and come out better you're
worse put yourself on sale and like
that's honest
and like so when guys hear when guys
hear healing like it's like a car okay
if it's got issues under the hood you
might be able to fix it but it still has
a history of issues under the hood and
you can repaint it and make it look
better but it's still a worse product
and it gets put on sale